Todos necesitamos la capacidad de comunicar información privada sin temor a que alguien nos espíe. Pero diseñar un
sistema infalible para esto no es fácil. En el episodio de hoy de Qiskit in the Classroom, hablaremos sobre cómo
algo llamado distribución cuántica de claves puede
ayudar. Bienvenido de nuevo a Qiskit in the Classroom. En esta serie, cubriremos temas que podrías encontrar en un curso
universitario relacionado con la computación cuántica. Cada video viene con un módulo interactivo enlazado en la descripción, así que
asegúrate de revisarlo. Hoy nos adentraremos en el ámbito de la criptografía cuántica. La criptografía es el estudio
de técnicas para la comunicación segura. Esto es increíblemente importante para muchos aspectos de nuestras vidas. Cada vez que usas una
contraseña para iniciar sesión en un sitio web, envías un pago digital, o cuando los gobiernos transmiten inteligencia militar, todo se hace
mediante algún protocolo criptográfico para que un espía no pueda conocer nuestros secretos. Pero hay una tensión aquí. ¿Cómo
nos aseguramos de que la persona con la que queremos comunicarnos pueda entender nuestro mensaje, pero nadie más pueda?
Históricamente, los criptógrafos han desarrollado muchos protocolos distintos para intentar hacer sus mensajes lo más inmunes
posible a los espías. A veces las dos partes que quieren comunicarse de forma segura acuerdan algún
código de antemano que, con suerte, es tan complicado que un espía no podría descifrarlo. Pero como
personas como Alan Turing y otros descifradores de códigos en tiempos de guerra nos han demostrado, incluso los códigos más complicados pueden ser
descifrados. Idealmente, nos gustaría enviar mensajes cifrados de tal manera que no haya absolutamente ningún patrón
y ninguna forma de que un espía pueda entender sin tener también una clave aleatoria secreta que solo el emisor y el
receptor conocen. Pero entonces nos exponemos a una nueva vulnerabilidad. ¿Cómo podemos enviar esta clave y estar seguros de que
nadie la intercepta? En 1984, Charles Bennett y Jill Brassard desarrollaron un
método para enviar de forma segura una clave con bits cuánticos, que ahora se llama BB84. La característica clave de estos
bits cuánticos o qubits que hace posible este protocolo es que obedecen el principio de incertidumbre. No puedes medir
un sistema cuántico sin perturbarlo. Hoy empezaremos con un ejemplo de un código criptográfico simple. Luego te
mostraré cómo la distribución cuántica de claves y el principio de incertidumbre nos permiten usar cifrados casi
imposibles de descifrar. Te guiaré por el protocolo BB84 en detalle y finalmente lo ejecutaremos en un
ordenador cuántico real. Primero, empecemos con un juego que quizás hayas visto antes llamado criptograma.
Se te da una secuencia de letras aparentemente aleatorias, pero usando tu conocimiento de los patrones del inglés
puedes sustituir una letra por otra para darle sentido al mensaje. Aquí hay un ejemplo. Este es un
mensaje secreto con un cifrado de sustitución simple. Así que todas las R representan una letra, las M representan
otra, y así sucesivamente. Si quieres intentar resolverlo tú mismo, pausa el video ahora.
Resulta que este mensaje fue cifrado usando un cifrado muy simple llamado el cifrado César, donde el
alfabeto simplemente se desplaza un cierto número, en este caso 9. Así que A se convierte en J, B
se convierte en K, C se convierte en L y así sucesivamente. Cuanto más largo es el mensaje, más fácil es
ver el patrón. Entonces, con un mensaje tan largo como el que tenemos, el cifrado César o cualquier otro cifrado que simplemente
sustituya una letra del alfabeto por otra es bastante fácil de descifrar. Una forma más segura de codificar un mensaje secreto
es con el llamado bloc de un solo uso. Con un bloc de un solo uso, puedes tener un desplazamiento diferente para cada letra del
mensaje. Solo necesitas decirle a tu amigo cuál fue el desplazamiento en cada una para que pueda decodificar el mensaje.
Esta lista de desplazamientos se llama la clave o el bloc. Se llama bloc de un solo uso porque se usa una vez y luego se descarta.
Si se usa más de una vez, surgirán patrones que podrían hacer que el cifrado sea descifrable. Con el
cifrado de bloc de un solo uso, tanto el mensaje cifrado como la clave individualmente son simplemente una cadena aleatoria de sinsentidos. Pero
cuando los juntas, ves un mensaje secreto emerger del ruido.
Hagamos un ejemplo corto. Digamos que ya creé y le envié a mi amigo este bloc de un solo uso, que normalmente se escribe en
binario. Y luego quiero enviar el mensaje "I love quantum". Entonces codificaría el mensaje
usando el bloc de un solo uso así. Primero convertimos las letras de nuestro mensaje a binario. Cada letra de la A a la Z
corresponderá a los números del 1 al 26 escritos en binario. Así que A será 0 0
0 1, B 0 0 1
0, C 0 0 1 1 y así
sucesivamente. Y un espacio será simplemente todos ceros.
Luego esto es en lo que se convierte el mensaje. Codificamos el mensaje realizando un XOR entre cada bit del mensaje y
su bit correspondiente en el bloc de un solo uso. Si no has visto XOR antes,
significa "o exclusivo". El XOR entre dos bits será uno si solo uno
de los bits es uno, y cero si ambos son cero o ambos son uno. Así que el primer conjunto de cinco bits en el mensaje codificado
se convierte en 1 0
0 1 1. Dejaré el resto de los XOR para que lo hagas por tu cuenta. Pero el punto es
que este mensaje ahora es simplemente una cadena aleatoria de ceros y unos sin ningún patrón. Es completamente indescifrable para cualquiera que
no tenga el bloc de un solo uso que usamos para cifrar el mensaje. Entonces, ¿qué hemos aprendido hasta ahora? Algunos esquemas de cifrado
son mejores que otros, y algunos pueden ser inferidos por una persona inteligente que busca patrones en el mensaje cifrado.
Pero una clave verdaderamente aleatoria que desplaza cada letra en un mensaje secreto una cantidad aleatoria diferente no puede ser
inferida porque no hay patrones en el mensaje. La única vulnerabilidad en un esquema como este es asegurarse de que
la clave que se usó para cifrar el mensaje no caiga en las manos equivocadas. Aquí es donde entra la distribución cuántica de claves.
Usando qubits, Bennett y Brassard desarrollaron una forma para que dos partes acuerden una clave y
estén razonablemente seguros de que un tercero no estaba escuchando en secreto. Este protocolo BB84 es un poco complicado, pero
lo veremos paso a paso. Para esta explicación, traigamos de vuelta a nuestros viejos amigos, Alice y
Bob. El protocolo comienza con Alice preparando un conjunto de qubits para enviarle a Bob. Estos qubits contienen la
información que se convertirá en su bloc de un solo uso o clave compartida. Alice primero genera dos secuencias aleatorias de
igual longitud. Una es una secuencia aleatoria de ceros y unos, y la otra es una secuencia aleatoria de X's y Z's que representan la
base en la que preparará sus qubits. Luego preparará cada qubit en un estado cuántico según la
combinación de la base y el valor del bit que se muestra en este gráfico. Así que si el bit es cero y la base es z, ella
preparará el qubit en el estado cero, o si el bit es uno y la base es X, lo preparará en el estado menos. Si
no estás seguro de qué son estas bases y estados cuánticos, no hay problema. El punto principal que necesitas saber es que las
mediciones en cada base solo tienen dos posibles resultados. 0 o uno para la base Z, y más o menos para la base X.
Si mides el estado cero en la base Z, siempre obtendrás cero.
Pero si mides ese mismo estado en la base x, obtendrás un resultado aleatorio, ya sea más o menos, cada uno con un 50%
de probabilidad. Entonces Alice podría preparar una cadena de qubits así, donde aquí hay una cadena aleatoria de
ceros y unos, y aquí hay una cadena aleatoria de x's y z's. Entonces el primer elemento en cada una de sus
dos secuencias era 0 y x. Eso significa que preparará el primer qubit en el estado más, y así
sucesivamente. Una vez que ha preparado todos sus estados de qubit, Alice le enviará a Bob estos qubits y Bob elegirá aleatoriamente entre X
y Z como la base en la que medir cada uno. Así que ahora añadimos algunas filas a la
tabla para representar las elecciones y mediciones de Bob. Aquí están las
mediciones y elecciones de base de Bob. Y aquí están sus resultados de medición de los qubits que Alice le envió. Finalmente, Bob
puede convertir cada medición en un bit usando la misma tabla que Alice usó para preparar sus qubits. Cuando mide el
estado cero o el estado más, asigna el valor de bit cero. Y donde mide el estado uno o el estado menos, pone un
uno. Entonces la cadena de bits final de Bob es esta última fila.
Nota que cuando las bases del paso de preparación de Alice y el paso de medición de Bob coinciden, sus bits también coincidirán.
Pero si Alice elige preparar en Z y Bob mide en X, o viceversa,
entonces los bits correspondientes de Alice y Bob no serán necesariamente iguales. Entonces, una forma en que ambos pueden acordar una cadena de bits
para su bloc de una sola vez es llamándose mutuamente y diciéndose qué bases usaron para cada qubit.
Cuando las bases coinciden, conservan el bit, y cuando no coinciden, lo descartan.
Entonces, en este caso, Alice y Bob acordarán una cadena de bits de 0 0 1 0
0. ¿Cómo protege este esquema contra espías no detectados? Bueno, veamos qué sucede cuando un espía
llamado Eve intercepta los qubits que Alice envía a Bob. Ella no sabe en qué estado están estos qubits ni cómo
los preparó Alice. Entonces, gracias al principio de incertidumbre y algo llamado el teorema de no clonación, ella no puede
simplemente hacer una copia idéntica de los qubits para pasárselos a Bob. Si pudiera, entonces podría
espiar sin ser detectada. En cambio, adivina una base en la que medir cada qubit, los mide, y luego
prepara un nuevo conjunto de qubits falsos para enviarle a Bob. Hay otras formas más astutas que Eve podría intentar para
obtener información sobre los qubits, pero ninguna evita el principio de incertidumbre.
Entonces, asumiremos este método directo de espionaje de Eve. Aquí hay una tabla que describe
la preparación de Alice, la interceptación de Eve, y la medición final de Bob. Ahora cuando
Alice y Bob hablan por teléfono para comparar sus bases, decidirán conservar estos bits para su clave, pero los
bits no coinciden. Esto es porque Bob estaba midiendo qubits que Eve preparó, no los qubits originales que Alice tenía.
Si comparan un subconjunto de los bits en sus cadenas de bits entre sí, verán que algunos no coinciden y
asumirán que debe haber habido un espía. Así que, dado que Eve fue descubierta, Alice y Bob descartarán
sus cadenas de bits y comenzarán el protocolo de nuevo. Pero si Eve no hubiera escuchado y el subconjunto de
bits que Alice y Bob compararon coincidiera, podrían seguir adelante y usar los bits restantes que no
compararon como su clave compartida. Una vez que Alice y Bob tienen una clave compartida, Alice puede enviarle mensajes cifrados a Bob, y
Bob es el único que puede descifrarlos usando la clave. Ahora que hemos repasado el protocolo, intentémoslo en una
computadora cuántica. Hay un par de cosas a tener en cuenta para este experimento. Primero,
BB84 solo es realmente útil si Alice y Bob están lejos el uno del otro. Para el experimento que estamos a punto de hacer, Alice
y Bob están en el mismo chip cuántico. Entonces, este experimento no será útil para intercambiar información privada, pero es
aún una buena demostración conceptual de BB84.
Segundo, las computadoras cuánticas reales tienen ruido. Entonces, incluso si la base de preparación de Alice coincide con la base de medición de Bob
y no había espía, todavía hay una pequeña probabilidad de que midan bits diferentes debido a errores en
la computadora cuántica. Cuando estén comparando sus cadenas de bits para buscar espías, necesitan tener cierta tolerancia a los errores antes de
concluir que un espía debió haber estado interfiriendo y descartar la clave entera. Ahora, con esas
advertencias, comencemos con un experimento sin espía. Primero, generamos aleatoriamente
tres cadenas de bits diferentes, cada una con 20 bits. La primera es la cadena de bits inicial de Alice.
La segunda es una lista de bases en las que Alice preparará sus qubits.
Aquí hemos elegido cero para representar la base Z y uno para representar la base X. La lista final es las bases en
las que Bob medirá cada qubit. Basándonos en esas tres listas, podemos hacer un diagrama de circuit con instrucciones para
la preparación de Alice y las mediciones de Bob. Todos los qubits comienzan en el estado cero. Para preparar sus qubits en
la base Z, Alice o no hace nada para el estado cero, o aplica un gate NOT o X mostrado como las cajas azules con la etiqueta X
para el estado uno. Para preparar en la base X, aplica un gate Hadamard que lleva el cero al estado más,
o un gate NOT seguido de un Hadamard para preparar el estado menos. Luego envía los qubits a Bob. El siguiente conjunto de cajas
en el circuit representa las mediciones de Bob. Para medir en la base Z, no necesita aplicar más gates.
Solo mide, lo cual se muestra con estas cajas grises. Para medir en la base X, primero aplica un Hadamard y
luego mide. Ejecutaremos este circuit usando el sampler primitivo del runtime de Qiskit. Y la salida es la cadena de bits
de mediciones de Bob. Luego podemos comparar las cadenas de bits de Bob con la cadena de bits inicial de Alice, descartando los bits
donde sus bases no coincidieron. Y vemos que ambos obtienen la misma clave.
Recuerda que esto es hardware real, por lo que ocasionalmente podría haber un bit que debería coincidir pero no lo hace. En este caso, todos los
bits coinciden, pero si ejecutas esto de nuevo por tu cuenta, podrías obtener un error, pero mientras la fidelidad esté cerca de uno,
Alice y Bob pueden estar razonablemente seguros de que no hubo espía. Ahora veamos qué sucede si Eve intercepta los
qubits. Ahora tenemos dos circuits. El primero muestra la preparación de Alice y la interceptación de Eve, y su
medición. El siguiente muestra la preparación de los qubits falsos de Eve y la medición de Bob. Podemos
ejecutar estos circuits como antes, luego ver qué obtendrían Alice y Bob cuando comparan sus cadenas
de bits. Esta vez obtienen una fidelidad de 6 repetido. Esto es mucho más bajo de lo que
puede explicarse por el ruido de la computadora cuántica. Entonces concluyen que Eve estaba espiando. La computación cuántica es
bien conocida y frecuentemente exagerada por su potencial para resolver problemas difíciles. Pero la comunicación cuántica y la criptografía
a menudo reciben mucha menos atención, aunque el potencial que lo cuántico puede ofrecer en estas áreas es igualmente
significativo y emocionante. Hoy discutimos el protocolo descubierto más tempranamente para la distribución cuántica de claves, que es
prácticamente inmune al espionaje no detectado. Si quieres probar suerte enviando un código inquebrantable con
una clave certificada cuánticamente, ve al módulo enlazado en la descripción.
Gracias por ver y nos vemos la próxima vez.